hi my name is greg alba and i am with the real
rejects uh i have i have seen your reaction video
as well we're in a stream of people whose reaction
videos have been devouring you guys are very
very well spoken so thank you for yeah uh
thank you dad um that just means the whole
world to me amber thank you so much for taking
the time to talk with me for some reason i feel
like i really need to communicate this uh i
really love this movie like a lot hey dakota
uh thank you for taking time to speak with me i
mean this is the most non-bullshit way possible i
really really love this movie a lot and i thought
you were just [__] awesome in the film as well
seriously thank you so much dude i was like 15
minutes into this movie and i i didn't even know
i was going to be talking to you and i was like
damn this guy's this guy's awesome oh that's
wicked dude it's gonna sound very unprofessional
but i really want to communicate this holy
i love the out of this movie wow thank you i
really did i'm a fan of this franchise and i
said this out loud uh when i was watching it i've
never cared so much about a main character in this
franchise like i was i was so rooting for you and
you were just excellent not only were you badass
but you brought so much emotional weight and um
i wasn't nervous when i got off the invite but
then i saw the movie and now like i'm a little
bit nervous to be talking to her right now so
that's so cool oh thank you that means the world
i mean obviously you know we worked really hard
on it for a really long time and like stuff like
that means so much to me because you never know
you go out there you make a thing you don't know
if people are gonna care about it so thank you
thank you so much man that just means the world
to me it was so much fun to make you know ride in
the horse fight and it was just a fantastic
time and to hear that you enjoy it i mean
it's just cloud nine for me i've never been
more excited to be part of a press junket before
just so i could tell you that because this
movie was awesome i could ask questions
for an hour or i could just spend the rest of
this time complimenting uh and reviewing this
before you guys because yeah wow it was
great i will ask real questions i promise
so dan with with the usage of the predator in
this movie there was so much of the time i got
like this this genuine fanboy sense of a director
going man if i made a predator movie here's how i
would capture it was there any particular shots of
the predator that you had always imagined bringing
a life that you brought to fruition here i mean
it's just the overall sense him lunging from tree
to tree is something that you sort of see in the
original predator kind of you know and ever since
then to me so often has felt like it's a it's a
professional wrestler in a suit lumbering around
and i i was the most anxious to include the feral
movements of an alien creature um back into the
franchise that was a huge part of it just merely
the way that he moved um was exciting it was it
was super exciting for me and you're right that
everything was like all right i'm doing this kind
of movie i gotta do it like every time i was like
i have to not be mad at myself i have to love the
scene i have to love this thing that we're doing
you know so yeah i i thought you you nailed it
it was scary and imposing and very like beast i
could i really could talk about it for forever
and i don't want to sound like a goddamn
kiss ass but yeah it was freaking awesome
so much of this uh character is in the body
language and you can feel so much history
and i'm curious like what was your research
approach to the character and also how much
did you build that we didn't even get to touch
on that perhaps you'd like to share some of we
we i say we built because to me the favorite my
favorite part of the movie is the comanche count
and that i mean we spent like the boys and i
spent four weeks in a training camp together
before we started the film and then we shot in
the comanche camp for so long and i think that
that on its own could be a whole hour and a
half of uh you know of a three-hour movie like
i think that is like all of them had like really
developed characters and really strong things and
and dynamics among the different characters and
stuff like that that i think is is really neat and
unique and then as far as just like naru herself
i really found a lot of importance in her dad who
they talked who like they touched on like oh
cool there's stuff like that but like that when i
like first started because that was like the first
scene that i ever read was where they talk about
that and so like going forward like that became
kind of a really big pinnacle to me was like
her father who was a hunter who left his
tools and she was not over and like he was
gone and even though she has a brother she
still feels the need to do this and like
i always thought was a really interesting part of
her that is not explored in the movie yeah and i i
i remember that moment that like look exchanging
you had with your mom and that in that scene
and that did stand out to me and that was like
the body language and i was like oh my god i could
feel so much history there so i really i really
appreciate that answer did all that homework built
on that is so cool yeah so you you play amber's
brother in this movie and i thought that there was
so much like unspoken yet yet sometimes spoken
sincerity and authenticity with your relationship
and i'm curious as actors how did you two go about
building a relationship when there's not exactly
a lot of exposition to talk about that history
yeah you know for me well we did the four week
boot camp before the show so we got to spend a
lot of time together me and amber and the boys
um and also we all hung out like all that we were
on the same hotel like just a few floors apart
so we would all be chilling you know in each
other's rooms just chatting hanging out playing
music so that was a really helpful to me but one
thing for me i wanted it to be not just jealous
older brother i wanted to be to be a caring
you know he's strong he's papa bear he's you
know but he also cares about his sister and her
well-being and also her doing what she wants to do
i thought that all really communicated some
of my favorite moments in this movie are those
tender scenes i've never cared about
predator characters so much before
like i gotta i gotta make that clear so i think
you guys really excelled in that for me i i wanna
say i i'm no comanche nation expert yet this film
reads up so much authenticity and i heard there's
a i heard there's the comanche dub voice by the
actors and in your honest opinion would you say
that is the preferred way or the best way to
experience this movie even though it's a dub
that is that really is you know that's the way
that dan originally pitched it you know the script
was written uh and it said what did it say dan to
to be yeah when you see everything from here on
out is spoken in comanche yeah so and me coming on
as a producer i'm like oh you had me at comanche
so you know perfect right perfect world perfect
world i'm gonna make sure to watch it again
in that fashion and then like 10 more times as
well so yeah that sounds great i'm a fan of this
franchise there's a lot of quotes in the original
predator film and i don't want to spoil it here
you were given a line that i was
like he said it he said the lie
how many retakes did you do you think you
maybe did on that and did you ever have
difficulty getting the original delivery out
of your head oh man we probably did five to ten
uh okay okay you know just because that's you
know that's the line you know for me that was
so exciting i saw it because that was originally
that originally wasn't there they might have i
think they might have had it in another spot and
before that they didn't actually have it there
but then when i read the sides that the
previous day i saw that on there and i was like
too much too much pressure yeah i know i was
so excited bro nah man you made it your own i
thought it was i thought it was really excellent i
mean it sounds like you're a fan of this franchise
so like other than the original predator and of
course this movie uh which predator installment
would you say is your favorite i really you
know the second one was cool uh danny glover i
like danny glover a lot he's got a good presence
but you know that that scene i think it was in
predators where that guy goes head to toe with uh
her head you know toe-to-toe with uh the samurai
sword yes yes it was yeah i thought that was
pretty wicked you're more badass in this movie
i'm not just sitting i'm not being hyperbolic
here this is a hell of a film and in many ways
the predator films are exploitation movies but
this also feels like a rare opportunity to tell
an earnest story from a time and perspective
we don't see much of in the mainstream
so what was the key for you guys in your
discussions and balancing like the sci-fi thrills
and kills that like damage is talking about but
also do it with like tastefully telling a story
about and depicting the culture of the comanche
nation yeah man it was that that was that was
the thing that was the reason to make was being
able to tell a movie that could work on a totally
visceral level and that also could have heart to
it so it's that the violence could be beautiful
that wasn't just a part of certainly there's
there's there's the template it follows it's
not that much unlike the original predator movie
we start out in one kind of movie and it becomes
something else and this version of it is is just a
historical adventure movie from the from the jump
and uh and i try to never leave that adventure
template as much as i could i really love the
idea of having that kind of having a little
bit of swashbuckle having someone sliding
around and in in quote-unquote quicksand and that
kind of thing yeah but even when the predator
shows up and the violence um happens i try i
mean i i mean i know that i needed to deliver on
the way in which it unleashes its might
and and the way it smites but i really hope
that there was still a way to be somewhat
elegant with the way that it kills and so
even though it's very gory and very rated
there's a lot that is not seen um up close
you know there's there's i think though it
uses its shield against someone in a tree
and we hide we show some things but we hide
other things in that in that moment um that's
sort of the ethos for what i wanted to do was like
sometimes we're very interfaced with the with the
more visceral qualities of the movie and sometimes
we're being quite the there's there's samurai like
you know kurosawa like moments um so i tried to
always have a little bit if i could say elegance
um even in the violent sequences it's something
that i i learned from doing 10 cloverfield lane
um that i always wish i could have done a better
job of the movie that movie was one kind of movie
and then it becomes something else and i think
in the filmmaking i shifted gears and i wish i
hadn't as much um and even in the lensing because
i had this other thing in mind that's too long too
long a story to tell right now it felt like the
movie shifted and i really wanted to make sure
that no matter what kind of scene knew that
this is a genre mashup filmmaking's still
the same kind of style throughout the throughout
the movie so it isn't just like it's handheld in
the beginning and then it's still late you know
like it all still feels like it's from the same
authorship i thought the build up and handling of
perspective and transitioning was just absolutely
excellent and uh i love technical field late
so i don't know what you're talking about
everything could be bad huh thank you max
and i i know that you're a director yourself
was there anything in particular that you learned
from dan that you think you could take it to your
next project well you really did your research
i respect it i am not i directed like two short
films when i was like 17 so i would not call
myself a director but i call you a director
i appreciate the cred i mean i feel like no that
if that is something that is in my future i think
it's very very it's not out of the question but i
think it's so far in the future because i have so
much respect for what dan does and his job i think
it's just so big and so consuming and i think to
craft to be the leader of a ship like this and
to craft an entire film and have it be good
from you know pre-production to shooting to like
to post and giving it to everybody i think it's
like i just think it's so incredible and i
think there's so many facets to what he does
is amazing and watching him do it was i
definitely learned so much from him but
i think there's no way that i could think that
like i could do that you know because i think that
he in particular is just incredibly gifted uh this
is for what i see that this is your first major
film role and it's both part of like a huge modern
franchise and it's also a cultural period piece so
obviously that's a really real like fortunate
position you earned your way into but what
overall has this experience meant to you oh
man well you know i've always wanted to act
but i honestly you know i was a musician and
i didn't really know if it was in the cards
because i didn't know anybody in the industry
and i didn't know how to get into the industry
um so i thought maybe if i'm a really good
musician i'll get like a hallmark movie and
then i'll like build my way up just to get this
experience on a multi-million dollar movie a good
movie you know with good director good people good
cast good producer um it was so educational and it
just makes you i mean i want to continue doing
this as long as i can so just the experience was
educational but enjoyable your first movie 10
cloverfield lane you have a female character
who has to overcome a lot of internal and external
fear and come into a place of their own with true
strength you also have something of a similar
parallel here is there something in particular
you're drawn to about female 1 i definitely am
interested in sort of conquering the perception
of someone who would that something that would
not be strong them conquering that perception
mainly because that's how i feel um that's how i
have felt my whole life so cinematically that's a
little bit more linked to that kind of protagonist
so that that i think is where it comes from i
think i found that i've gotten a lot of strength
from my mom and my wife their influence on me
perhaps more so than other men in my life or that
that i that i've been friends whatever it is you
know and that's a big part of the story that's
a little bit more under the surface is a story
about someone who's rejecting the wisdom from
her mother who wants her to do medicine and she's
doing all this other stuff and the thing that
really saves her butt is embracing what the mom
gave her um so it isn't just about can a girl
become like a guy you know it's more about like
you need to embrace all the things being a strong
part being the alpha being the top dog it's not
just who has the biggest muscles which by the way
predator is kind of about that too the original
um it's not that far off from it so it's just
coming in from a different angle i thought you
absolutely nailed it i even told amber actually
that i was like i've never cared so much about a
about a character in the predator franchise before
so it was accidentally done i gave up meat because
of my love for animals and i read that you also
have a passion for animal rights yes something i
actually wasn't prepared for uh was the amount
of animal deaths in this movie and i know it's
all like pretend and effects but was any of that
difficult to participate in or watch back in the
final cut it's interesting i think that the way
that i feel about animal rights is different
from other people who maybe feel that way because
it's like i'm not i'm not vegan like i eat meat
i love meat all that stuff i tried for a while
and it honestly was just like not my body is like
not built for that like i really totally get it a
good try and it was not happening i've put a lot
of thought into this because that was definitely
like a large passion that i had especially when
i was like a teenager and like into my early like
around like you know 2021 and and animal rights is
it's it's so largely about like the way i think
also that we like view animals and we treat like
wild animals like it's like and you live it
i think people find different ways to live
it so like the way that like i live that in my
life is like i don't use any like cosmetics or
like skincare products or anything like
or household items that are like tested
like that's where i find that you know and it's
like even on shows like i'm sure to like tell my
makeup artist like you know that's really like hey
this is kind of my boundary and stuff like that so
yeah but i think that there's also a way that it's
like that's also kind of like the natural order
of life going back historically we always ate
meat it was just done with like a much more
i think like respectful and mindful way of
like you know taking lives and like not wasting
anything and like also they had a good like
animals had good lives like while they were
living it's not like now when it's like i don't
know chickens are raising like you know stuff like
that like it's just like bad and stuff like that
but i mean i do still like eat meat and stuff i've
just found like yeah yeah it's hard to live all
of it at once i feel like as far as like conscious
consumption just in general i feel like you have
to like pick a few things and then go with that
you know otherwise you can get so overwhelmed
trying to like save everything all the time and
then you're failing but no i think i've just found
like i stick to those things no i appreciate that
honest answer i'm not as like particular about
the products but more about the food yeah yeah
yeah pick and choose especially actually i asked
you about the movie that too while we're at it but
i really really love that answer um would you say
that music is your first passion uh before before
acting and what kind of music do you do uh it's
kind of like a country americana kind of thing
not the uh not the annoying pro country but like
you know like kind of old school you know and i
would i would like to con i'd like to continue
on both of them to be honest they don't want to
necessarily give one a priority over the other
uh i certainly don't plan on giving either one
up maybe putting one to the side for a moment
depending on what kind of opportunities arise but
i i will definitely be doing my best to continue
acting as long as i can that's so great to hear
i can't wait to see more uh very sincerely because
it's actually one of my things when i was watching
this movie was i really noted how reflective of
the emotion the music was in this film so like
what was your take on the oh yeah you know the
music is like it's always been a big part of me
uh for film like watching if the music is bad it
drives me crazy but the first time i saw the movie
uh there's this tune called like nadu's journey or
something like that but it's so cool i just love
that they weren't they didn't overdo it with the
drums and the flutes you know i'm saying they like
you know they had some strings in there i was just
so pleasantly surprised you know because you you
know you never know like how things are gonna turn
out but when i first heard it i was just happy oh
yeah no it made my heart move it always created
the suspense and the tension it was beautiful but
uh seriously man uh you have so much to be proud
of here and i love this movie i genuinely love
your performance i know i loved it because i got
nervous to speak to you so thank you for being
such a cool dude to talk to man thank you for oh
thank you bro i really appreciate it i think i'm
you're on youtube yeah yeah i'm on youtube i might
have seen i might have seen did you do a reaction
video to us yeah it's the trailer yeah i was so
into it and i was like yeah i think i saw that
no yeah i appreciate that thank you brother
definitely thank you so much i really enjoyed
uh talking with you i love how we didn't even talk
about any predator related things i think that's
so cool i love everything that we actually spoke
about this is really a great time and uh major
major congratulations to you and thank you for
being so courteous and open and vulnerable while
we were talking i really appreciate you thank you
so much all right take care seriously thank you we
have a great predator moving in it's something it
was even more than that thank you thank you both
thank you so much keep on doing what you're
doing too man thank you thank you take care